he was the head of this footballing
family his loss has left them
heartbroken shock sadness disbelief and
then this for a man who dared this club
to dream and took them all the way to
the top the players led by the
Chairman's son surrounded by a growing
sea of tributes inside the stadium his
widow and son sharing their grief with a
team who taken him to their hearts they
won't just his employees Glory's friends
knew his friends you know and that's
what we built this Football Club on you
know the foundation it sounds a long
going over the top but you know it's
just that is exactly what it was his son
the club's vice chairman known to fans
as Top nearly always traveled with his
father but this week he wasn't at the
game or on board the helicopter seen
here arriving on the night to collect
the passengers who'd be on its final
fatal trip how did this happen the
question for investigators still
examining the wreckage and flight data
recorder also killed with two of the
Chairman's staff along with the pilot
Eric swather and his partner and
co-pilot Isabella lukovitch the pair had
years of flying experience they filmed
this in 2016 he's been praised for
bringing the helicopter down away from
the busy stadium his heroism no surprise
to friends the moment I heard that the
moment someone mentioned that I said to
myself that's Eric because that's
exactly what he would do he would put
safety first all this even if it you
know endangered his own life and the
moment I heard about it I said you have
that that's exactly what Eric would do
he would try to save a whole bunch of
other people just to you know get the
aircraft safety on the ground at the
stadium the tributes keep coming the tie
football team rescued from a cave
earlier this year among those here to
pay their respects a book of condolence
will open in the morning what happened
here
knocked this city there is a sense that
people just need to be here together to
make sense of it all gone but never
forgotten
this man will always be a Leicester City
legend Becky Johnson Sky News Leicester